all right jesus christ
jesus [ __ ] [ __ ] christ i have no idea
what the [ __ ] is going on i told him
during the break i'm like look i'm
trying
really really hard not to get annoyed
but i'm yeah really
did everybody go get a bathroom break
because that was a good time to do that
yeah i told everybody how to go to the
camp yeah i went to the canada in the
last
yeah i was talking about santa tila was
uh was talking about
we're talking about florida and tomorrow
yeah florida new york
and california you could definitely
t you could definitely sell your house
in [ __ ] san francisco and buy a
[ __ ] florida mansion you can
in a nice neighborhood housing is
cheaper yeah
yeah and more extravagant there's a lot
more room here
and it's just the prices are better and
the lifestyles
chilled out it's not like california or
new york or boston at all very chilled
out i mean it's probably not going to be
like that for much longer because
they're building
everywhere and i feel like it's kind of
like it's got another 15 years in it
before it starts getting a little too
crowded you have to move up to the damn
panhandle
you just have to move out it doesn't
matter where you live anymore most
people are living online
or working online so it doesn't matter
where you live
you know what i mean you don't need to
live in a place to work which is kind of
nicer
very nice although like i'd still rather
live somewhere where it actually
look at places like southern california
and places like new york boston and
detroit
which i've been to all of them they're
old places and
people lived there because they had to
work there that's where the industries
were
not anymore you know not anymore
you can live wherever you want to if
you're
they got guys here in florida that are
[ __ ] if you were to
they're working from home but
if you see what they're doing they're
actually [ __ ]
working for some kind of damn stock
exchange somewhere in new york
this is the this is where all the the
rich people from new york [ __ ] have a
vacation home they're all living here
now
they're remotely doing their jobs from
here back in
[ __ ] new york that's what they're
doing
so location doesn't matter anymore well
like i said that's nice because maybe
you know in in a decade or so that might
shake out to everybody just like
actually living to where they want to
live yeah
you don't have to live in a particular
place that you don't like just because
of work
said it before on the shows within a
decade or so
there won't be cities as you know them
because
they'll be technologically obsolete most
of the country will be kind of something
like a suburban setting
seriously i'm kind of i honestly some
people
are like all kind of like oh they're all
like pessimistic about the future i'm
like dude the more [ __ ] i can do from my
couch
yeah the better my life is
technology technology is cutting out a
lot of middlemen that were parasites on
us
the scams are going away that's why
they're so scared
the the ruling class was built on these
scams
like banks you need banks banks are an
endangered species
[ __ ] a lot of the [ __ ] commercial
real estate endangered species
just a lot of the [ __ ] that they made
their empires on
are are going obsolete like print
newspaper
gone you know
[ __ ] it's just a new era we're seeing
the end of the old
and the beginning of the new and really
the power the power dynamics and the
powers behind
the throne do not like it but [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them they're like vampires
you done i'm done okay i'm done all
right so is that what i got to say
okay so let's talk about some more
suspects
um yeah they're all in go ahead and go i
skipped one guy because he i
felt like he was probably bullshitting
yeah but let's talk about this dude
ld cooper or lynn doyle cooper if you
want the whole thing
he died in 1999 spoiler alert
now he was a veteran of the korean war
uh he was also a leather worker
now he didn't get uh put forward as a
suspect until 2011 and his niece
actually did that
what is with all these [ __ ] family
members like narc and others like hey
my dead relative is probably d.b cooper
you know what i mean maybe there's a
book deal in it i don't know
but uh she says the niece she's like
when i was eight years old
um uncle ld
uh and another uncle she overheard them
saying that they were planning
something very mischievous which you
know
air piracy that's pretty mischievous um
on the mischievous scale i suppose um
and also that this uh whatever
mischievous thing they were doing
um involved some expensive wonky talkies
so she said that she heard them talking
about this at
her grandmother's house in oregon which
uh
not that far from portland i guess 150
miles that's pretty far
now she says that the day after she
heard them talking about this
was the day the flight got hijacked and
she also says that that day these two
uncles were supposedly out hunting for
turkeys
and later that same day she says that
uncle came home wearing a bloody shirt
uh he said he'd been in a car accident
and uh she also says too that her
parents were convinced that her uncle
ld or lynn doyle if you prefer uh
was actually dan cooper the hijacker
now the uncle uh died in 1999 but the
niece also pointed out that ld cooper
was super super into that comic book i
mentioned earlier
the one with the hero with dan cooper
and that he actually had like some
covers of it like
pinned up on his bedroom wall so
maybe i don't know like he had the same
last name
and uh some people said too that when
this whole uh
theory was circulating that there was
another eyewitness sketch
different than the more famous ones from
the flight crew
where i guess it was like a passenger
uh that was on the plane that saw him
and then like left the plane later on
and he said that he's seen the dude that
he saw had like horn room sunglasses on
which the dude did have sunglasses okay
um
and he had a russet colored suit jacket
which
i don't know if that's accurate because
a lot of people said that he's just had
a white dress shirt and a tie and like a
black or like a dark overcoat i don't
know
but he said wavy hair now the weird
thing about this i read the wikipedia
page about this
and it said he had and i quote
marcelled hair and i was like what the
[ __ ] does that mean
so i had to look up and this is not
a usual thing for me because i'm like a
vocabulary nerd right
so it's very rare for me to come across
a word that i have no
idea what the [ __ ] that like marcelled
hair what does that mean
so i had to look it up and it was like
some h like not ancient but like some
really old term
that essentially meant wavy it was like
some specific kind of
perm or something that they didn't name
marcel had that yeah i guess
but it's like it wasn't capitalized or
anything i'm just like i have never
encountered that
term in my whole entire life and uh so
yeah so we have like some wavy hair but
particularly i guess it's like the
marcel kind of wavy i was it was like
different than the regular wavy i don't
know but
it's like so he had hair like that um
so apparently this dude had hair like
that and
so did this uh you know sketch of the
person that one of the other passengers
gave
so they're like hey you know maybe this
is
this is them but uh they did do a dna
profile on this tutor at least on his
family members because like i said he
had died in 1999 the dna profile didn't
match the dna profile
they'd found on the tie flip but as the
fbi authorities pointed out we're not
entirely sure
that the dna that we found on this tie
was actually actually belonged to
the actual hijacker db cooper so we're
not ruling out the possibility this
could be that guy so
you know we're just saying one of the
more intriguing suspects at least
as far as i'm concerned uh was a woman
barbara dayton now uh she was born in
1926
she was a recreational pilot and worked
as a librarian at the university of
washington
she was actually born robert dayton she
was in the u.s merchant marine and then
the army during world war ii
had worked with explosives in the
construction industry
she wanted to be a professional pilot
but back in the day
you're a woman that wasn't really
happening
so uh some people speculate that moosh
was pissed off about that
and dressed like a man to pull off the
whole db cooper thing
because she was pissed about not being
able to be a pilot
um fbi has really never made a public uh
statement about this
like i said she died in 2002. possible
sure but who knows i just thought that
was interesting because it's like i
i thought that was really amusing if it
was actually like a woman dressed to the
man i don't really know
so this other uh suspect here william
gossett
now he was in the marine corps army and
the army air force's uh veteran
he was in korea and vietnam he
had advanced jump training and
wilderness survival
so he actually retired from the military
in 1973
he worked as an rotc instructor taught
military law at weber state university
in ogden utah
and interestingly hosted a radio talk
show in salt lake city about paranormal
[ __ ]
yeah it's cool did we do a show with him
maybe no he died in 2003 so no that was
a long time before
now this dude he kind of came on the
radar because he was like super super
into he was really really interested
in the db cooper hijacking he had a
whole bunch of articles like he was one
you like you know when you see in the
movie like the serial killer and he has
like all the [ __ ]
you know the the articles all over the
walls it was kind of like i'm imagining
that scenario except with
articles about db cooper he had um like
all that kind of [ __ ]
now reportedly and i don't know if this
is true like i said because this is like
you know witness testimony which is not
real reliable
but apparently when he was real
old he had three sons um
and he told them as well as like some
friends of his that were kind of like
high up
muckety mucks and whatever like judges
and [ __ ]
that he was d.b cooper right so he
supposedly told his kids that and told
like a bunch of his kind of high-ranking
friends now photos taken of him in 1971
also kind of look like the sketch
which like i said the sketch that
they're pretty sure is fairly accurate
um also there was a thing where
okay so there's this lawyer i don't know
if he worked for him directly or if he
worked for
the family but
apparently this dude showed his sons
that he told that he was d.b cooper he
said
look this is a key this is to a safety
deposit box
and in this safety deposit box is all
the money
that i took from the ransom that's where
it went it's in the safety deposit box
um so the
oldest son that they interviewed he said
yeah dad was like
really he was uh really into gambling
and uh
he was always like spending all his
money so he was always looking for like
ways to make more
and he says the oldest son says my dad
showed me like a whole bunch of cash
uh just before um
christmas in 1971 which was only like a
month after
the hijacking right so he's like hey
look at all this money
now his son says maybe he went to vegas
and blew it all
which wouldn't that be something if d.b
cooper did like actually steal all that
money which is over a million dollars in
today's money
jumped out of the flame jumped out of
the plane made it
and then it went to vegas and blew it
all he just like lost it like in a
single wouldn't that be hilarious
i mean yeah it kind of would be yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
i'm just saying but that would be funny
so 1988 like his kid said
okay this is funny to me too so in 1988
walter gossett uh inexplicably
changes his name to wolfgang
as you do and um he's supposed to change
your name
some [ __ ] like wolfgang
what's your name my name will gain
wolfie like yeah like wolfgang holidays
mozart
and also as if that wasn't enough
changing your name wolfgang
also became a roman catholic priest
so he was his name so he's a pedophile
that was changed his name
uncut [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i am very strange to me it's very
strange
so um so yeah there's a couple of other
things about this dude that maybe
maybe not but like i said there's a lot
of things about all of these dudes
that kind of sounds like it could be db
db cooper but i don't know but it
for some reason it does amuse me to
think that he like made all this money
and like survived this big
epic heist and everything and then just
like went to [ __ ] vegas and blew it
on like a single
you know spin on the [ __ ] roulette
wheel or whatever
that's just like i don't know it's
really funny to me
all right so one of our other uh
suspects
robert lepsi not leprosy pepsi
now the only thing about this dude was
that he was a little bit younger
uh you know when the hijacking took
place than what they
than how old they thought he was because
at the time he's only about 33 years old
now he managed a grocery store and he
was married he had four kids
now he was from michigan grayling
specifically
he uh disappeared from his home in
october of 1969.
they found his car about three days
later at an airport
and uh somebody saw or at least a person
like matching his description
boarding a flight to mexico a few days
after that
um they figured that he had probably
left voluntarily there's he wasn't a
missing person even though his family
has reported him as such
and uh so the epi are like yeah whatever
we're out uh you know he obviously left
and that's not against the law now
two years after the uh
family members of his were like man he
looks a lot like that [ __ ]
uh drawing and the clothes that
d.b cooper was said to be wearing looked
a lot like this dude's
uniform like where he worked now this
guy
because they never did find him he
actually got declared dead in 1976
because like i said he had vanished in
1969
um one of his daughters did actually
later submitted dna sample
in 2011 to be specific uh although
i don't think they ever reported the
results to the public so i don't know if
they matched
or not now this to me was very
interesting we need to do a whole show
on this guy
because he's also a suspect in this
another suspect in this was john list
now do you remember who that is that's
that dude
that accountant that killed his whole
family
and like left him in the [ __ ] house
yeah
like some like movies and [ __ ] on him
where he just like killed his whole
family and left them in there
they caught him eventually though they
did yeah um
now he had served in world war ii and
korea yeah he ended up murdering he he
murdered his wife his three
kids who were teenagers and his 85 year
old mom this was in new jersey
um and he left him on the house now he
killed them all
about two weeks before the hijacking
uh he had with withdrawn about two
hundred thousand dollars
interestingly as much as uh d.b cooper
asked for
in ransom money he took that amount of
money out of his mother's bank account
like i said two weeks prior to the
hijacking and then he vanished
um now he was actually a suspect because
of the time that he disappeared um
the fact that he looked a lot like the
witness description of what d.b cooper
looked like
um and also the fact that maybe because
he had murdered his whole family and
didn't really have
a quote unquote a lot to lose that maybe
he would have been desperate enough to
pull off this kind of [ __ ]
uh they did catch john list in 1989
he did admit to killing his family but
he
denied being db cooper um
so he uh he died in prison in 2008
so like i said we will never know if
that dude was [ __ ] bb cooper or not
wouldn't that be something if it was
man is saying she could never get
[ __ ] good sushi in florida no not
that when you lived here
not now we got [ __ ] great sushi now
we got some places [ __ ] like koi won
we have all you can eat sushi
and then all the different rolls and
everything [ __ ] no we got good [ __ ]
here
then we got a little we got little
places where you have little
korean it's actually korean guys that's
not japanese guys the japanese don't
come here and make that but the koreans
do
we've got another little korean place a
little japanese sushi place
across the street from my bar around the
corner yeah that place was [ __ ] great
it's closed now but that place is
[ __ ] great
yeah we went there a couple times yeah
you have those [ __ ]
what was that [ __ ] [ __ ] volcano roll
[ __ ]
crap spider roll all the different
[ __ ] rolls no we got everything here
this shit's good real
good yeah i mean if you as long as you
come to like don't go to like some
[ __ ] rural place because yeah
you know don't do that but if you come
to like an actual city
yeah um you know we do actually have
some decent [ __ ] here we got a [ __ ]
place here me and jenny go to called
koi wan koiwan is a gigantic
chinese slash japanese
buffet that has a [ __ ] stream
running through the middle of it with
little [ __ ] bridges that go over it
with gigantic cart [ __ ] swimming around
in it
and you can get [ __ ] everything there
man [ __ ]
they got hibachi where they'll [ __ ]
cook you up some [ __ ]
they got all the [ __ ] chinese food
and then all the sushis pre-made up
there
it's [ __ ] it's like a chinese
disneyland of food
shit's awesome it you know it's just
no no no look i'm from california it's
kind of
boring there the florida of today
[ __ ] is [ __ ] not the florida
californians think exist it's [ __ ]
awesome
well like i said as long as you go i
mean orlando is a pretty
diverse city you can get pretty you can
get good sushi here you can get good
indian food here you can get all kind of
everything
you can get pretty much anything you
want in downtown
downtown orlando there's a whole section
up called little vietnam it's all
vietnamese
restaurants there's really good thai
restaurants there's all kind of good
[ __ ]
when i was a kid growing up in southern
california it was not a pre-planned
society in terms of the way it looked it
was just
suburban sprawl everything just mushed
in together
just [ __ ] constant suburbs and
garbage looking houses
that's not the way [ __ ] florida looks
it looks like
disneyland manicured [ __ ] everywhere
a lot of differences between the houses
yeah everything's new
and it just looks like [ __ ] paradise
because i mean yeah you got [ __ ]
neighborhoods
but they're old they were they were
built there a long time ago
it looks like a one [ __ ] it looks like
an amusement park
tila says good cuban food in florida
yeah oh yeah
oh in tampa i mean you can get good
cuban food here too but tampa
was really good i used to get cute they
got a [ __ ] soul food restaurant right
across from [ __ ] tom's [ __ ] place
just
with tom the [ __ ] black dude a friend
of mine who owns a [ __ ] club here
[ __ ] right next to it is a [ __ ]
soul food [ __ ] restaurant that would
blow your [ __ ] socks off
it's got that [ __ ] what was that
stuff that i had there was called
[ __ ]
[ __ ] what was the name of that [ __ ] i
had it and i was just
damn what was that that i had jenny i
don't remember you ordered it too
it was no i didn't i got i got you got
something else yeah yeah i got fried
shrimp
it was it was jerk chicken yeah jerk
chicken and rice
ah man now we have everything here it
was good
we have everything here and um
everything is pretty
here much prettier than unless you go to
like shitty neighborhoods yeah that's
good
conserve some [ __ ] there it's more
spaced out everything's spaced out and
everything's kind of pre-planned and
you got paths that walk through
everything and round [ __ ]
trees and [ __ ] little bricks on [ __ ]
and just looking everything looks like a
park and
just everything looks like it's part of
the disney corporation
that's why they're moving here well like
i said everything's kind of newer
yeah everything's brand new you have to
think that in the early 70s most of
orlando was a swamp
yeah it's a swamp and then like disney
came and you can find neighborhoods that
were built in the
60s and the 50s and 60s and they're
still there they're dilapidated and
[ __ ] up looking
but you know once that population
changes over they buy all that [ __ ] up
pacando's there
you know just it's just a nice
and they're building new [ __ ] here like
all that and socially the environment
it feels like california in the
late 70s early 80s it's a laid-back
environment it's not
doesn't have a high population density
it's a good income
it has a rational government um they're
just trying to make sure that you don't
have [ __ ] people
pissing on everything and throwing
[ __ ] needles everywhere and you know
you know it's just you know what i mean
it's it's a better neighborhood
florida is a better neighborhood even
[ __ ] the panhandle
it's like mississippi with trailers but
i could still live there
you know take [ __ ] yeah
mississippi's more quaint little bitty
old-fashioned houses and little villages
yeah yeah it's more quaint yeah more old
school more traditional
but okay we gotta go back traditional
yeah it's like traditional it's like
well every time i go there i feel like
i'm back in the 70s yeah i was like like
a little like backwards
[Laughter]
you know what i mean it's very black now
all the white people moved away like i
said my my dad lives at heidelberg
population 700 he's the last white guy
and it's black mayberry and you know
they take care of him and [ __ ] when he
got sick they [ __ ] called the
hospital
visiting him in the hospital and
everything bringing that turkey next
and bringing him turkey necks national
guard guys you know what i'm in [ __ ]
there
going to the [ __ ] doing parades down
the middle of the [ __ ]
streets and [ __ ] and it's just like
they're experiencing
the miss mississippi the black
mississippi population
that's rural is experienced in the 1950s
it's like
for them it's like um you know american
graffiti
that's what they're experiencing so it's
like just an america it's cyclical
a cyclical it's their time now yeah
yeah everybody's moved away so they're
running it
yeah yeah that's the way [ __ ] works
yeah i know yeah um okay so
let's talk about some more suspects okay
so this guy
okay now if i did not believe that
dan cooper aka db cooper
probably died during the jump um
then this would be my prime suspect i
think
this is a little dude named richard
floyd mccoy jr
now this dude he was a he was in the
army he was a veteran
he had served two tours of duty in
vietnam uh
first time around he was a demolition
expert
and then he was with the green berets he
was a helicopter pilot
now after he got out of the service
he was a warrant officer in utah
national guard
and he was a recreational skydiver
now the thing that brought him to the
attention
of authorities was that
on april 7 1972 only a few months after
the db cooper hijacking
richard floyd mccoy jr uh
pulled off one of the best known of the
so-called
copycat hijackings now listen to this
[ __ ]
this dude gets on a united airlines
flight 855
which was also a boeing 727 just like in
the db cooper case
with aft stairs just like in the db
cooper case
he gets on in denver colorado um
he had a paperweight that looked like a
hand grenade but he told everybody it
was a hand grade
he had a handgun it was unloaded
he wanted four parachutes just like d.b
cooper
and he wanted five hundred thousand
dollars now he got the money delivered
to him
and he got the parachutes delivered to
him at san francisco international
airport
and then just like in the d.b cooper
case
richard mccoy says
tells the plane to take back off and
then he bailed out over provo
utah and he left behind his hijacking
instructions and his fingerprints on a
magazine that he had been reading so he
did the same
[ __ ] that d.b cooper did
like six months later same [ __ ]
i don't know if it was copycat or if it
was just like db cooper pulling another
one
i don't know sounds like it could have
been copycat but well that's what
they're
thinking but it's possible obviously if
you pull off something this similar
um then they're gonna suspect you for
the actual [ __ ]
too now they actually did call in a hot
handwriting expert
which you know okay i know that that's a
thing but it's like i don't know
how objective that science is you know
what i'm saying
um now they compared
uh there was a note found on the plane
with uh richard mccoy's writing on the
military service record
and they found out that he had written
the note so he
pulled off the heist like he jumped out
of the plane he lived he got
away um but he got caught only
like two days later so you know uh
because they matched his handwriting up
now they found when they caught him uh
he had all the cash on him
so you know guilty
now he got uh they put him on trial and
he got convicted of 45
years however two years later he escaped
from prison
by crashing a garbage truck through the
main gate of the prison with a couple of
accomplished
uh comp accomplices um
he was free for about three months and
then they found him
in virginia beach and he got into a
shootout with fbi agents and got killed
damn so he wasn't giving up
i guess not so you gotta give him that
seriously you gotta give him that was
his name again
richard mccoy was this dude d.b cooper
we don't know he pulled off like i said
it was a very very similar
i don't know if it was just because he'd
read about it and he's like yeah i'm
gonna try that [ __ ]
or if it was db cooper and he's like i
lived through the last one now i'm gonna
do this other one
let me go back again [ __ ] what was
his background
military yeah vietnam korea
two tours airborne he was uh
he was a demolitions expert and then he
was in the green berets he was a
helicopter pilot
and he was a recreational skydiver okay
yeah that could have been him
and um and like i said about six months
after the db cooper thing he pulled off
an almost exact uh
thing but why would he need to do it
again so soon if he escaped with the
money
see i don't bull maybe it wasn't enough
maybe well like i said maybe he didn't
have any money in his possession
when they caught him no like where his
house was oh i don't know
when they caught him he had all the
ransom money on him
yeah but what about the money from if he
no no one ever found that
other than what they found on the bank
of the of tina barr that they see
that sounds like the kind of guy that
could have done this heist
well yeah that's why this like i said if
he did if i didn't think that d.b cooper
probably died
this would be my topic yeah the thing is
though
is that there wasn't any money from the
[ __ ] from the
db cooper heist at his house there's no
connection to him to that money
you know they would have gone to his
house to see if he had a stash
unless he laundered it i mean did he
have a bank account i mean
what's more on this how was his living
conditions was he living well or was he
living poor well see no one's ever
brought that up i don't know
like i said he got caught well he got
caught
in this other heist and that was only
like a couple months
like a few months after the other one
i'm suspicious
i think what happened is this guy had
the prerequisites to do the heist and
was inspired by d.b cooper said i could
do that too
because if this was him he would have
had the money from the first heist
even if it was laundered that had gone
to his house and found a big pile of
money
they said well this isn't the original
money but he switched it out with some
other guys for their money
you know laundered it yeah already had a
big bank account
with laundered money in it so he didn't
have the money
see well not the 200 200 000 is like two
million dollars back in those days
like a million dollars like i think
somebody in the comments no that was
closer no it was a million
he would be living well still six or six
months later
unless he blew it all we don't know yeah
and
you know like you said maybe if he blew
it blow it in vegas or whatever
well yeah and now let now i will say
that
the fbi agent that shot
and killed richard mccoy
seemed to believe that that dude was
also d.b cooper hey i killed d.b cooper
but some other fbi agents that have
investigated the case
don't really think that they're like no
we think that he was in vegas
on the day that uh you know the the
hijacking the db cooper hijacking
occurred so it couldn't have been him um
and maybe he was
at home in utah with his family on
thanksgiving so it probably could have
been him but i don't know but like i
said
i kind of feel like i i'm leaning toward
maybe probably
d.b cooper died jumping out of the plane
but if he didn't
i think this dude is the most likely
suspect i'm just saying just because
a few months later he pulled off an
almost exact
yes it could be copycat but
the fact that he did the exact same
thing
and lived i don't know that that just
makes me like
suspicious so
that's well yeah well nobody has that's
why i know it's like and you like you
said earlier we're not going to solve
this [ __ ] i'm just saying like what my
personal opinion is
so um one of the other suspects a dude
named sheridan peterson
now this was a dude that was in the
marine corps during world war ii
uh he actually worked for boeing like i
said a lot of people did
kind of believe that maybe db cooper
worked at boeing because of some
particles like found on his tie later on
um and the plant that he worked at the
boeing plate that he worked at was
actually based in seattle
so like i said this whole area where
that took place
now he was uh experienced as a smoke
jumper
and he was also known as kind of like a
risk taker he was like really into
daredevil kind of [ __ ] um also he was 44
years old
at the time hijacking and uh looked very
similar to the sketches
um so basically like some people that
have looked in this case are pretty
pretty sure
this guy is the dude um
this guy died very recently uh just very
early this year oh thank you very much
mango 25 pounds cooper cash
flash bulb yeah it was me all along
hitting them flash balls
now we know mango badger is d.b cooper
you heard it here
first you heard it here yeah jumped out
jumped out over the usa and landed in
the uk
no wonder they never found him hit the
ground [ __ ] 40 years
and several thousand miles away
but yeah so uh so like i said some
investigators are very convinced that
this dude is
is them he died very recently just
earlier this year like january 2021
he was 94 years old so if that was d.b
cooper he lived a really [ __ ] long
time
yeah he didn't [ __ ] try to get to get
credit for what he did if it was him
if i'm 94 i'd be like [ __ ] it was me
i did it
yeah but a lot of people do that though
yeah nobody pays attention when old
people yeah that's true because they
say all kinds of stuff yeah yeah
whatever all times
but yeah well i kind of feel like that's
what happened i'm dv cooper well yeah
cause like i said some of these suspects
that's why they looked into it because
like
they were dying and they're like by the
way i did that [ __ ]
i won't tell you i'm not telling you
[ __ ] son
i'm not only your
[Laughter]
actually i'm lying i spent that [ __ ]
on hookers and blouses spit this [ __ ] on
on ass
[Laughter]
went down to vegas met the man named tom
he had a huge stable
did nothing but just buy a bubble but
for three months
oh [ __ ] million dollars gone
yeah yeah that's it that's my db cooper
son
that's old db coop which he would be now
yeah
i mean he'd be like zombified at this
stage wasn't even booty was bubble butt
big hit that was a big difference yeah
snow bunnies running around
around and [ __ ] flip flops [ __ ] were
wearing flip-flops
every time i run it [ __ ] just [ __ ]
bounce out
where's my camera
where'd my cialis a dude like that would
wear a condom
i'm not buying it yeah yeah don't matter
you're not gonna get pranked
oh [ __ ] well yeah okay i'm done
are you sure yeah i'm doing it are you
sure yeah all right
so all right so let's now i feel like
silly like even talking about this case
anymore because
you're going off on something all right
so let's talk about another
suspect this dude is named robert
rackstraw
now uh this dude he was a pilot
he was retired he was also an ex-convict
he had served on an army helicopter crew
and uh
during the vietnam war now he was
actually one of the earlier ones not
that early but uh he kind of came to the
attention of the fbi in
uh 1978. now he got arrested
in iran and he got deported to the
united states
uh to face explosives possession
and check kiting charges so he had tried
to like run to the middle east and he
got brought back
now a couple months after that they
brought him back to the u.s
and he got out of bail and then he tried
to fake his death
by being out i don't know if he was
actually out in a plane but he like
tried to
convince him that he was out in a plane
and the plane was crashing
and then so like he sent out a false
mayday
and he's like yeah i'm bailing out on
this plane because it's going to crash
so he tried to like fake his death right
yeah um
authorities didn't really fall for it
they caught him a couple days later
and um also they caught him
and they were like hey we have all these
other things we can charge you with
including
he had actually forged uh federal pilot
certificates
so you know uh but the plane that he
supposedly had crashed
i guess he like repainted it and just
put it back in the hangar again
so it's like but they knew it was the
same plane
um so this guy again
looked a lot like the composite sketches
that's the thing about the like the
composite sketches of db cooper
actually really good and like i said
they're pretty sure they're accurate
but what percentage of dudes
in their mid-40s looked like that in
their early 70s obviously a lot
because they had a lot of suspects
like a lot of people look like that they
were held over from the late 50s and the
60s
that damn flat top haircut they had yeah
the glasses
they had a conservative kind of
paramilitary look to them right right
you know the draft was going on a lot of
guys got you know you guys got drafted
yeah uh you know and they get you early
enough it sticks with you
some dudes [ __ ] love it no i saw
i saw the sketch and i'm hearing all
this this dude's ex military
he's ex-military he was into that [ __ ]
he had a big ego
all right he's proud of this [ __ ] that
he did i'm just saying
i would be too it was like i said it was
a pretty uh
trying to outdone he's he's a
working-class guy with skills he's got
some intelligence he doesn't have that
much to lose he's in his sport he's
he's like you know [ __ ] it they you know
i only got 20 years left anyway maybe
15.
i'm gonna [ __ ] get some [ __ ] that's
what he's thinking i'm gonna steal some
[ __ ] it's gonna be bad
y'all gonna love it i'm gonna jump out
of plane people be talking about this
[ __ ] like 50 years from now yeah
exactly just gonna [ __ ] shoot [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
here i go into immortality yeah that's
what he's doing
yeah pretty much so he's doing i'm
flying
got your money splat yeah yeah he
hits the trees he hits the trees i'm
pretty sure that's all that's yeah
he hit the trees and [ __ ] hurt
himself real bad and didn't survive
could have been something where he had
that wrong parachute and it didn't open
he's like oh [ __ ]
we hit and just bills went [ __ ]
flying you imagined
going through all the trouble of
requesting four parachutes and then
picking the one
that didn't work yeah i got your money
[ __ ] yeah it's like
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man it's like that's what happened
[ __ ] figures
that's what happened that's some [ __ ]
that would happen to me right well he
was going [ __ ] [ __ ] proud with it you
know i mean i got this [ __ ] yeah i'm
running into it
oh no oh [ __ ] bills [ __ ]
fluttering then they go in the water and
then [ __ ] 10 years later they find
them on the [ __ ]
shores he buried them that [ __ ] is dead
[ __ ]
bugs got him that's what highway you
know wouldn't it be something if like
[ __ ]
a year or two from now they actually
found a skeleton and they're like who's
this
it's a skeleton with some glasses and a
flat top a big bag of money
and a big bag of money there he is
we wondered where you were pieces all
this time yeah
pieces of a [ __ ] parachute [ __ ]
all around
it's too long ago he's he's this whole
time here he is
well yeah like i said this dude had a
lot of the you know
checked a lot of the boxes however one
of the things that
kind of goes against it was that in 1971
this dude was only 28 years old
now it's possible that he could have
been a real
road hard and put up wit kind of 28
years old
um because everybody that saw him
thought that he was in his mid-40s
but you know unlikely
so uh here's this other guy okay now
this guy
i think this guy didn't even come to
light until
maybe like two years ago so this is a
dude
this is the one that i was referring to
earlier okay
walter recka reika i'm not sure how you
pronounce that
walter reika so he's from michigan just
like sophie
yeah uh he was a military veteran
obviously uh
he was an original member of the
michigan parachute team
now he didn't actually get put forward
as a suspect
until 2018
i believe like a friend of his like put
him forward it's like maybe it's this
guy
so basically okay so 2008
walter ricka confessed to being db
cooper to his friend
his friend's name was carl carl lauren
and he was a
an airline pilot and a parachute guy
like
you know he was a parachuter now
lauren had recorded the calls
so he has recordings from 2008 of this
guy saying
like admitting that he was db cooper
right in july of 2018
they did a documentary where they played
the recordings
now walter um
he died in 2014 so he's dead now but
before he died
he gave like a notarized letter and he
had written his whole story out to his
friend he was 80 years old
and he's like okay you can tape the
phone conversations i'm gonna tell you
all the [ __ ] about it
it was you know six weeks they talked to
each other on the phone he wrote letters
and whatnot
so the details that he gave about the
hijacking
there was some [ __ ] in there um that had
never been released to the public
right basically um
he said that he landed near somewhere
named and i'm not
sure i'm pronouncing this right because
i'm not from the pacific northwest
um clay alum
clay alum c-l-e e-l-u-m
that's in washington state okay so he
said he landed near there
and that he got a ride in a dump truck
from a dude named jeff unpronounceable
last name
ozia dash ozia dax something like that
he said he got a ryden dump truck from a
dude named that
um on the night that he like fell out of
the plane
and uh this dude jeff that was driving
the dump truck
he corroborates this story he's like
yeah i was driving my dump truck down
this road
and i saw this dude walking down the
side of the road
um and the weather was really shitty and
i thought
the dude's car had broken down uh and he
was walking to like
find help he's like well i didn't have
room in the truck
to like give him a ride because it was a
dump truck so
he's like so i just kept driving and i
went to uh this cafe that was like right
there on the side of the road
and i stopped in there and then he's
like i went in there i ordered coffee
and then the guy came in to this cafe
and then i started to talk to him he
said this guy came in he was all wet he
said he looked like quote unquote a
drowned rat
came in there he's like the guy sat next
to me
and said um hey if i
give you my if if i call my friend on
the phone
can you give him directions to where
this is
so he can come get me and uh
jeff's like yeah sure whatever so he
says this guy
who we're assuming is d.b cooper um
called his friend up on the phone and
then he gives the phone to jeff
and jeff's like this is where we are
this is our coordinates or whatever
and he said that's what he did he gave
him like [ __ ] coordinates
then he said jeff like took off because
he had to go like go to some club he was
in a band or something and he had to go
play with the band
and uh he said this strange man d.b
cooper like i said
said hey i'll buy you know i'll buy your
coffee or whatever and he's like yeah
thanks man thank you very much
and then he didn't see him again now
the interesting thing about this is that
so walter reika who is this dude that
like i said on his death deathbed is
saying that he's d.b cooper he described
the area where he landed
um he said that he saw he described the
two bridges that he saw
he said he saw like this particular
configuration of lights which apparently
is very distinctive in the area
um he described the what the cafe looked
like
on the inside and outside he described
the
uh talking the conversation that he had
with this dump truck driver
uh jeff with the unpronounceable last
name
he described that um and he said that
jeff was wearing like
cowboy looking stuff like western
clothes and he had a guitar case which
was true
um so you know so he knew a lot of
details and the details that he had like
corroborated with what this
other guy had said so
basically so a lot of people are kind of
like
like i said this is a fairly recent
development and um
so a lot of people are kind of convinced
maybe this dude was like i said he's
dead now he died in 2014
but he did like know a lot of [ __ ] about
it and there was like some corroborating
evidence from other people that were
there
um so they kind of like uh set all that
up
and also um walter recka
said that yes he was wearing like a
suit or it wasn't entirely a suit it was
like a dress shirt and
pants and then like he had an overcoat
but he said that he also had
long underwear on underneath the
clothing which if true that would have
been a pretty smart thing to do because
like i said it's [ __ ] november
it's the you know end of november in
pacific northwest you're gonna jump out
of a [ __ ] plane you better be wearing
like some [ __ ]
warm ass clothes rather than just a
[ __ ] dress shirt and pants
so it would have been smart to have some
long underwear on and that was one thing
that kind of
struck me because he's like yeah i had
long underwear on underneath my
clothing so um
so this story like i said the dude died
he was 80
in 2014 and he had all these letters
they he
he told to do the [ __ ] over the phone
and there was corroborating evidence
from the other dude at the cafe
so you know um they actually went to
this dude um in 2016
uh the friend he kind of went to a
publisher
and they got somebody to look into it um
that kind of went through all the you
know
passports photos like newspaper
clippings all that kind of stuff
and while he didn't determine
definitively obviously that this dude
was
dan cooper he did say well it doesn't
look like any of the [ __ ] that
uh from that time period was faked it
all looks like it came from that time
period all looks like
uh you know legit um
so the fbi they they kind of went
through and like cross-examined like
everything with the fbi [ __ ]
and they were like well we can't rule
him in but we can't rule him out either
because nothing in there is like says
that it wasn't him
and it's totally possible that he could
have just
fallen out the plane and then came to
the road and then got picked up by
somebody that's kind of what they
thought
happened um you know he didn't get
picked up but he just went to the cafe
and the dump truck driver saw him
and like i said there was some
corroborating evidence there so you know
that was kind of like an interesting
thing that just came out
fairly fairly recently um so there was a
book that came out about it
in like mid-2018
and it's called getting the truth i am
db cooper like i said that dude's dead
now
so i don't know but his friend actually
did seem to believe that he was
uh d.b cooper there were a few other
ones as well
there was like this dude william smith
um he was from new jersey and uh
you know he he was the same kind of
thing he was a navy veteran he was 43
years old
during the hijacking and he had kind of
some of the same
you know [ __ ] and one thing that was
interesting about this dude william
smith
was that he worked for
after he got out of the navy he worked
for the penn central valley railroad
railroad and there was like a big
bankruptcy that happened with that
company in 1970
and um there was some [ __ ] that was like
at that time i think that was like the
biggest like corporate bankruptcy
like in the u.s at that time and i think
that he didn't get like in his pension
and he might have like
had a grudge about it and wanted to like
take it out on somebody or like get some
[ __ ] money to retire on or whatever
so they kind of feel like that maybe was
you know a factor as well
um also one of his uh
high school friends was named
ira daniel cooper uh and that
classmate of his was killed in world war
ii so they're speculating maybe he took
that dude's move that was a friend of
his and he took that dude's name
you know what i mean and he had like an
aviation background
he knew a lot about parachutes he knew a
lot about planes and he also had a lot
of railroad experience so they're
speculating that maybe if he jumped out
of the plane like he knew to just jump
on a train he knew where they were going
so there was that kind of whole thing
too and you know
like i said there's tons of other ones
and i feel like we've been going on
forever and ever
um too many guys that are [ __ ] uh
have the prerequisites required to do
this [ __ ] job well that's what i
that's what's like crazy to me is that
there's a lot of dudes
this kind of [ __ ] happens and then they
find like a thousand dudes
easily that could have done that could
have done it right it's like somebody
that was like a military veteran that
knew all about
planes and parachutes that knew all
about this area that had a grudge
against
boeing or had his or had some other
thing
that made them a suspect i mean
it just kills me so there's this other
dude dwayne weber
this was another one where it was a kind
of a deathbed confession thing
uh he was a army veteran from world war
ii
uh he was also a uh habitual criminal
he had served time in at least six
prisons from 1945 to 1968 usually for
forgery burglary [ __ ] like that um
his widow actually put him forward for
consideration after he died
uh because of a deathbed confession
three days before he died
he died in 1995 he apparently told his
wife
i am dan cooper she didn't know who that
was at the time but when she
researched it later on allegedly she was
like holy [ __ ]
and uh she looked into it and then
reported it later on
uh she said that he had
said things in his sleep like he would
have nightmares
where he would say things in his sleep
about jumping out of a plane and leaving
his fingerprints on the aft stairs
she said that she heard him say that
multiple times uh he had a knee injury
which was consistent with a skydiving
injury
uh he also chain smoked smoked uh you
know drank bourbon all that kind of
stuff
so he uh was also supposedly
[Music]
in the seattle area in 1979
right along the river like where that
money was found and they're speculating
that maybe he put it there like
you know later because the money wasn't
found until 1980 so maybe he put it
there in 1979 seems like everybody wants
to [ __ ] claim to be
well like i said this is a very famous
yeah it's a very very famous case
so obviously there's going to be i mean
obviously it was just one dude
um the fact that there were so many
dudes that it could have been
and there's also the very uh real
possibility that he didn't make it
which to me seems more likely
but i don't know i'm open to the
possibility that he maybe got away with
it but like i said the fact that
the the only fact that's getting me
is that none of the other money has
turned up no one has ever
found none of that other money with that
serial nut with those serial numbers
have turned
up and to me
man unless he had like a really good
[ __ ] money laundering scheme
lined up i just can't see that happening
i mean you would think that
at least one of those bills would turn
up somewhere you would think that
yeah and see the thing is the guys that
are claiming to be that dude they didn't
have pride and have a pot to piss and
where's the [ __ ] money
yeah because i mean the whole point of
pulling off a stunt like that buy some
[ __ ]
you need the money yeah you need the
money to do something that's
crazy and you're going to buy at least a
house and get yourself set up and start
your operation
maybe go out and do another one looking
for icing on the cake
that that didn't happen it's you know
what that dude jumped out of the
airplane and [ __ ] died on
impact yeah i think he probably is going
to happen and they just haven't found
his body yet because like i said it's
something
you'll never find his body like i said
it's possible he still survived i'm not
saying he didn't because other people
have done it and survived but
i kind of feel like in that case
probably just the fact that the mon the
rest of the money never turned up i
think he probably died
the other guys that did it were caught
immediately they worked tells you
something
because like i said now let's talk about
very very briefly like before we end up
let's talk about a couple copycat
hijackings because this is
the it's it's uh illustrative you know
of what kind of thing can happen
so um obviously there had been some
cases like this uh prior to uh
d.b cooper's stunt um
honestly earlier in the same month there
was southern dude
named paul joseph cindy i think is how
you pronounce his last name he was
canadian
and he hijacked an air canada dc-8 over
montana
but uh he didn't get too far like the
crew pretty much uh overpowered him
and uh because he put the he had a
shotgun but he put the shotgun down to
put the parachute on and then they all
jumped on him
um so but after db cooper's
thing there was a whole bunch of like it
was like hey that's a good idea let's
try that
so there was this dude named garrett
trapnell
he hijacked a twa airliner
going from la to new york city that was
in january
of 1972 i believe he wanted
the very specific amount of three
hundred six thousand eight hundred
dollars in cash
also wanted to talk to richard nixon
also wanted the release of angela davis
um but the aircraft landed at jfk
international airport in new york city
and
the fbi agents shot him and wounded him
and then he got arrested
so uh another guy richard lapointe
he was also an army veteran um he got on
the hughes air west flight 800 at
mccarran airport in las vegas
january 20th 1972 um
he again said he had a bomb even though
he probably wasn't a mom uh it was a
dc-9 it was still
on the taxiway he wanted fifty thousand
dollars two parachutes and a helmet
which is something that d.b cooper
didn't ask for you'd think he would ask
for a helmet if he was accurate
parachutes but you know whatever
um so he let the 51 passengers off the
plane and the two flight attendants
and then he ordered the plane back into
the sky
wanted to fly toward denver now he
jumped out
over north northeastern colorado
however uh the parachute that they gave
him had a like a tracking device on it
so they were able to find it also he
left like a bunch of footprints like in
the because it was snow and there was
mud and [ __ ]
so they found him only a few hours after
he had jumped out the plane so he did
survive the jump
but they found him all a few hours later
um as i mentioned earlier
richard mccoy who like i said if d.b
cooper did live i think it's probably
this dude
uh he hijacked a united airlines 727 in
april
only a few months after the db cooper
hijacking and
uh asked for five hundred thousand 000
jumped out of the plane
landed safely but got arrested two days
afterward
he was another dude named frederick
hahnemann hahnemann i guess
uh he actually used a handgun to hijack
eastern airlines 727 in allentown
pennsylvania
in may of 1972. he wanted 303 000
uh he parachuted into honduras which was
where he was born
they found him uh actually he actually
ended up giving himself
up like a month later because the fbi
was after him they had a 25 thousand
dollar
bounty on his head and he was tired of
running so he just gave himself up
there's another dude named rob heady or
hidy
he was a vietnam veteran and a
paratrooper he jumped on a
united airlines 727 in reno nevada in
early june of 1972
wanted 200 000 and two parachutes jumped
into the darkness near washoe lake
about 25 miles south of reno again
survived the jump
but they found uh the cops found his car
parked near the lake and uh arrested him
as he went back to it he left the car
there
so he could jump out the plane he's like
can't believe my car that went to the
boat
and then they just waited by his car and
like they arrested him when he went to
the car
so you know he he had a plan but it
wasn't a very good plan
um another dude named martin mcnally he
was a service station attendant but was
unemployed
he used a submachine gun in late june
1972
to commandeer an american airlines 727
and route from st
louis to tulsa then diverted it eastward
to indiana bailed out with 500 000
and ran some money when he jumped out
the airplane he lost all the money
damn it's probably my plan he didn't
have it secured
yeah i guess not uh it ca can you
imagine like going through all that [ __ ]
and then all the money just flies away
just like you know what [ __ ] my life
[ __ ] my life
uh he did land safely near peru indiana
and was apprehended a few days later in
a detroit suburb
so 1972
saw a total of 15 hijackings similar
to db cooper's take place all of them
unsuccessful the dudes were either shot
by police or were apprehended within
hours or days of the actual hijacking
but after 1973 when new laws were passed
where they would look through
everybody's luggage and all that kind of
[ __ ]
uh the incidences of these types of
crimes
dropped dramatically because everyone
was looking into yeah it's like they
know what they're doing
well back in the day you could basically
just like walk onto a [ __ ]
like yeah i'm this dude you could put a
fake name on there pay in cash
get on a plane with something that
looked like a bomb well what happened
was
you can't do that nowadays obviously
cooper k the dv cooper caves
went mainstream so every [ __ ]
ex airborne dude that needed cash who
was [ __ ] crooked
could go oh yeah i'm gonna do that too
that was a good idea but of course they
[ __ ]
they quickly [ __ ] closed that
loophole of being able to get on with
some kind of bomb or some kind of a gun
to [ __ ]
to get the people under control to
hijack the plane
hijacking was a fad i remember that it
really was
i mean there was really kind of a they
were hijacking the thing
hijacking planes and take me to cuba and
[ __ ] for the [ __ ] revolution and
all that kind of [ __ ]
they're full of [ __ ] although that
wasn't the majority the majority of them
were actually for
ransomware just like david cooper yeah
only
only like a dozen of those things called
sky
marshals which were cops yeah we're on
the [ __ ] plane playing clothes with
[ __ ]
pistols to [ __ ] apprehend dudes that
did this kind of [ __ ] and they just rode
around [ __ ] federal aviation
commission [ __ ] had them in there
they started taking counter measures can
i just talk about before we
before you wrap up because like i said
they you know obviously they passed a
lot of the laws
you know that you have now about air
travel because like i said it was very
freewheeling back in the day you could
pretty much get on a plane with anything
you could just like come in you could
put a fake name on there just like
checking into hotels back in the old
days you should put a
[ __ ] fake name pay with cash and then
you could just get on with whatever the
[ __ ] in your luggage no one would check
um so after 1973 you couldn't do that
anymore so
obviously the um you know the hijacking
thing went way down like after 1973
after all these laws were passed however
i love this so there was another similar
incident
which happened in 1980 in july of 1980
so this dude named glenn tripp and he
hijacked northwest flight 608 at seattle
tacoma airport
same airport he wanted six hundred
thousand dollars
two parachutes and he wanted someone to
assassinate his boss
okay which i'm not really sure how you
thought killed my boss for me
i i'm not really sure how that's [ __ ]
working
but that was one of his demands okay
initially [ __ ]
this is why i love this story wait it
gets better okay so
he's off he's on the plane with his
demands
one of the flight attendants uh a very
quick thinking flight attendant was like
i'm gonna drug this [ __ ]
right so she gives him some uh he asked
for a drink obviously because he thinks
he's db cooper give me a bourbon and
soda whatever it was he ordered
she put valley in that [ __ ] oh yeah
valium to the [ __ ] or he i don't know if
it was a male or female flight attendant
but uh yeah
put valium and that [ __ ] uh and he got a
little loopy
so at this point there's a ten hour
standoff
uh during this standoff uh the hijacker
reduced his demands i love this he
reduced his demands from
six hundred thousand dollars two
parachutes and please assassinate my
boss
to can i please just have three
cheeseburgers and a head start on
getting away
i read that and it just made me laugh so
hard that made me laugh so hard
it's like just for negotiating down and
i thought this [ __ ]
obviously obviously not um
what happened to him uh so okay so what
an update
dude so he he got uh arrested obviously
because
he's an idiot now but
three years later 1983 he was still on
probation for that [ __ ]
and he tried it again same
uh it was northwest airlines it was the
same
flight number like the same route he
tried to hijack it
again and he wanted to be flown
to afghanistan of all places
afghanistan why afghanistan in 1983
yeah why the [ __ ] would you want to go
to afghanistan why would you want to go
to afghanistan now but why would you
gonna
get a state of 1983 for all well of all
places probably because it was a [ __ ]
a stateless area in other words there
was no
government probably no government in
afghanistan in 83 it was just a bunch of
tribes
so it's the same it's three years later
he's still on probation for the earlier
[ __ ]
yeah same same flight number
same route i think there might have been
a little same airline there might have
been some mental problems
um clearly yeah so he gets on there fly
me to afghanistan
um they're like yeah sure we'll do that
they land the plane in portland and then
the fbi guys shot him
dead i am
it was too much trouble well yeah you
know what
i'm sick of you i kind of feel like that
was an issue
but yeah so like i said we did not solve
the db cooper case
because no one will ever solve the db
cooper case you think he died
i'm kind of leaning toward probably he
died
um i like to think because he put so
much
thought and effort into it it would bum
me out if he had died just like jumping
out of the [ __ ]
but i don't know i lean toward that
being more i'm kind of leaning to it
seventy percent
more likely that he just jumped out the
plane like i had impaled on a trigger
all you gotta do is look at the other
cases i fell in the river
you gotta look at the other cases where
guys did that okay
they weren't successful they were
apprehended very quickly
most of them made it down to the ground
safely
they did all right
well they can't all make it down to the
ground safely so that tells me that
what happened was that that dude did not
make it to the ground
safely you would have heard from him you
would think
yeah and like i said he did plan a lot
of [ __ ] ahead of time but the conditions
were really really bad
although the thing about it though that
kills me is that
he seems to have planned a lot of [ __ ]
ahead of time like he seemed to have a
[ __ ] together he wasn't freaking out he
wasn't
you know he seemed to know like the lay
of the land he was real calm and [ __ ]
so why if you were having this plane
they were totally happy to fly you to
mexico city man
why would you jump out over
an area that you possibly weren't
familiar with and
that was so dark that was so cold that
had such heavy cloud cover that you
weren't exactly sure
where you were jumping why would you do
that
when it would be much easier to just
wait for better conditions
because there was still like a long way
to go right yeah well he told them to
take him to mexico city
sure but they were stopping at reno
first because they had a refuel
i want you on a bet he had no intentions
of ever going to mexico city maybe he
didn't
it was just something to tell them to
try to get them to go south
yeah they'll like maybe throw him off
there right yeah because he wanted to go
south
but he told him mexico city because that
was south
he knew he was going to jump out before
then
yeah it's just it's a weird case all
around like i said it just seems like
he didn't make it it's one of those
cases where it seems like
really really he seems really really
competent and also really really
incompetent at the same time
well the other guys had a clearly
planned
escape route once they got into the lz
which like i said that's like the most
important
right but yeah that's what's
okay so well yeah that's kind of like
the [ __ ] clincher isn't it because
you have to have a good you need to have
a plan once you land
right but that's how they got caught but
that's how if you have a plan then it's
all the more likely
you will get caught that someone else
will figure out what your plan is right
and we'll be able to apprehend
i don't think he had a plan
at the lz maybe he thought well if i
don't have a plan then they won't be
able to catch
no it's gonna be random right but then
he was like
what that forced him to do was to
attempt a landing in an unprepared
lc filled with a bunch of [ __ ] trees
and when he hit that [ __ ]
at [ __ ] 30 25 30 35 miles an hour
he caught a [ __ ] tree limb in the
dark right on that [ __ ] head and
killed him
or maybe in the leg and broke his leg
then he hit the ground and he's out in
the middle of nowhere well yeah because
he made that back even if he even if he
didn't die like even if he was just hurt
enough that he couldn't
it's kind of a good chance that because
they didn't see any uh
they didn't see any parachute and they
did find some money supposedly buried
that he he didn't he wasn't killed
directly on impact
he got injured on impact he hid his
parachute
carried the money for as long as he
could buried some of it to reduce the
weight
and then kept on moving and died later i
think he died
then honestly i'm kind of leaning toward
that being the most quote because i
don't know necessarily i don't know if
he
necessarily died like on impact i think
he just might have got hurt and he was
out in the middle of the wilderness and
he didn't have a plan
well if you get injured on impact that's
almost the same as dying
well yeah because if you like die a few
hours yeah what are you gonna do
and it was like really really cold in
that cold too
he's not which actually that's a sign
that he didn't plan why didn't he have a
[ __ ] heavy
jacket well see that's what a lot of
people said it's like he wasn't really
dressed for it
right that's what kind of struck me
though about that whole walter record
guy because that guy did say oh i had
long johns on underneath my
suit which would have been the smart
thing to do honestly
airborne infantry would know that well
[ __ ] i can have an lce
on and all kinds of stuff with a [ __ ]
poncho poncho liner and some food and
water
and i'll put that in my [ __ ] back in
my [ __ ]
carry-on luggage and then once they
give me my parachute i'll put my lce on
but just like a [ __ ] battle belt when
you call today with suspenders
you know it i'll have it i'll paint it
orange or some [ __ ] like that or
something to make it look
like non-military right
let me just jump out with that and i'll
have everything i need when i hit the
[ __ ] ground
you know and you can live out there for
days if you have the right support no
problem
yeah did you shoot together yeah you get
together which you would think that he
would
it's telling me that this may have not
been his [ __ ] primary plan
maybe had a plan for something else but
it fell through something that they do
for whatever reason and the crew was
being reasonable with him and he
believed them
so he's like okay well i guess plan a is
gone we're gonna go for plan b
or plan b plan c there's something else
yeah some kind of a backup plan i don't
think this was the real plan
maybe not because it really seems like
very i mean compared to
you know the really thought out first
part of the plan
the second part of the plan seems pretty
half-assed i gotta say seems like he
where did he ask to go first well he
always wanted to go to mexico city yeah
but after they told him
that they're like look the plane can't
go from seattle tacoma airport to mexico
city we have to refuel so then the
discussion was
where like what route are we going to
take where are we going to stop to reach
okay where he asked to go to mexico city
he probably thought they were going to
fly in a straight line a straight
azimuth to mexico city
his primary target was probably along
that straight line
he's like if i go straight to that line
in four hours after the flight i'll jump
and i'll be
where they're waiting for me he might
have had some guys on the ground waiting
for him
and they'll pick me up yeah maybe i mean
you would think that we can't do that we
got to divert to this other place
and he's going well [ __ ] that takes me
off the azimuth i need to go over my
prepared lz
now the fact that he chose that he
agreed
to reno nevada because there were as far
as i remember there were a few other
cities bandied about as to where they
could land to refuel
on the way to mexico city and the fact
that he agreed to reno
says to me that well whatever
plan he had going like once he got to
the ground
maybe reno was the nearest thing right
yeah he's like well that's more south
that's
like a haunt 200 miles versus 300 miles
from where that's what i'm saying so it
maybe wasn't ideal but
i mean it was like closer than anywhere
else it's probably what they proposed
he's not going to tell them where he's
going well obviously no
yeah but he's trying to get them to move
in that direction without telling them
where he has to go he got in there and
they said well we can't take that route
we have to [ __ ] stop over here first
and he's like [ __ ]
that takes that takes me away from where
it is i wanted them to go
yeah maybe that's what it was maybe
that's why it seemed like he didn't
really have a plan
but he did have a plan it's just that
they couldn't [ __ ] do it they
couldn't accommodate sure
i mean you know but yeah so
get ahead he gone all right we'll go get
the fuel instead of taking me to [ __ ]
mexico city take me to uh
[ __ ] philadelphia because he's
thinking
that'll [ __ ] divert us back towards
where my lz is
but they'd figure that out right they'd
go what is a long
this azimuth and then this athemas where
does that [ __ ] correspond to on the
map
so yeah because he seemed like he was
trying to like divert attention from
where exactly
yeah he didn't want them to triangulate
where it was he really wanted to go
which they were doing so he wasn't dumb
about that but he was there was a backup
plan
where okay guys i'll um if i can't get
to you
i'll [ __ ] jump in another location as
close as i possibly can
i'll call you and then you guys come get
me so that's probably what it is
yeah i kind of figured like i said if he
survived i don't know if he did or not
i don't think he did i suspect probably
not but it's possible he did
he landed in an unprepared lc got
injured and that led to his death
that's what i think happened but like
you said um
because of this particular case and it
being
so high profile um 1973 saw a whole host
of new laws come in
about [ __ ] uh you know
people go like you know them being able
to go through your luggage
uh so you know they brought in the uh
the air marshall program like you
mentioned before
so after that like pretty much as i said
the end of 1971 was the db cooper
hijacking there were like 15 copycat
ones like after that
um 1973 there were only two hijackings
that whole year and both of them were by
psychiatric patients
so you know it was crazy people um but
yeah so like i said we didn't solve it
we're never going to solve it i don't
think anyone's going to know it's too
late to solve
um until we unless we find his skeleton
someday
right with all the money next to him and
the chances of finding that are about
nil
the animals got that a long time ago
probably well they didn't eat the bones
though
they might be in the water yeah that's
true i mean
because some people have said that he
did get washed down in the [ __ ] river
scattered that [ __ ] around over the
years you
you know be bones and skulls all over
the place
yeah disappear in that [ __ ]
wilderness man all right so you're ready
to like wrap it up yeah go ahead and
wrap it up and go get the kitties
yeah we've got to go get the kitties i
actually kind of want them to eat too
i'm starving
all right um but yeah so uh sorry we
dropped out a bunch of times yeah um you
know i can't really do anything about
that i'm just
yeah i'm trying to like i try to like
have it not do that i try to restart it
but it doesn't always work out but you
know sorry
so thanks for hanging in there with us
on this friday evening
hope you guys like this new time slot i
kind of like this new time slot because
now i can like sleep in tomorrow no i
don't have to do anything so that's
pretty awesome
uh but yeah remember if you like the
show like share subscribe on all your
social media please
if you would like to support the show
you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com
10 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog13clockpodcast.wordpress.com and
there's a button in the sidebar to a
paypal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation
it's much appreciated always uh good to
have support from you guys
to help us out on our show and like i
said earlier we've changed our schedule
around
um hopefully it's meets to everyone's
appreciation expectations whatever um
you know it'll it'll it'll work out
it'll be fine and like i said
there might be some new movie reviews
coming in april that i'm going to do
on my own as well so thanks everybody
for stopping by on this friday night
we will see you guys on sunday yeah
because we're going to do a matinee on
sunday
and uh again thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for your
contributions
and we will see you on sunday bye